so how do we test out how our desktop
application works with a touch interface
if we don't have a mobile device handy
well it turns out the chrome developer
tools let us use the mouse to emulate
touch events support on a non-touch
desktop just open up the chrome
developer tools go down to this gear
down in the bottom and under overrides
select enable and emulate touch events
now close the overrides but be sure to
leave the devtools open you can minimize
them to get them out of the way and now
as you move across your interface you'll
see the cursor is represented by a small
dot this is emulating a touch event
cursor and clicking the mouse is the
same as pushing your finger down or
lifting it off now you don't want to
rely on this too much it isn't perfect
and it isn't exactly like having a real
touch interface so be sure to test on a
real touch interface and a mobile device
as well